here's a person who's gonna be dealing
with some of that whether it's
Maryland's Republican governor but he's
got other things on his mind he says he
has serious doubts that President Trump
can win a second term Larry Hogan was
reelected in November by double digits
in a blue state with one of the largest
minority populations in the country only
on CBS this morning
Hogan reveals he's hearing from people
who think he should consider a primary
challenge to the president ed O'Keefe
spoke with the governor at the Maryland
State House this morning at his in
Washington heed good morning good
morning John 62 year old Governor Hogan
has one supporters on both sides of the
aisle for his straight talking style in
recent months he's renewed his concerns
about President Trump this week for
example Maryland became the only state
led by a Republican governor to sue the
Trump administration over the national
emergency over border security you know
I think the president made some real
mistakes here and I don't think it
declaring this using the declaration of
emergency powers it's the right thing to
do and I think it should be challenged
so in your view it's not a national
emergency well it's certainly not we've
exaggerated the what's going on at the
border but we do have some issues down
there and here's my dad standing up to a
president of his own party is something
the governor learned from his father
former congressman Lawrence Hogan
Republicans were mad as heck at him for
decades really some of them and never
you know the White House was pretty
furious but in retrospect people say man
what courage who in 1974 became the
first Republican congressman to publicly
call for Richard Nixon's impeachment no
man not even the President of the United
States is above the law I probably
learned more about integrity in one day
from watching my dad during that crisis
than most people learn in a lifetime now
Hogan believes many in today's
Republican Party have forgotten his
father's lesson I do believe that there
are people in Congress and other leaders
in the Republican Party who have not
stood up when they disagree or when they
think that the president is doing
something wrong I've not been afraid to
do that well let me ask you this since
you're such a straight shooter is the
president fit to be President
look I'm not in any position to judge
the the fitness of the president you
know I've been pretty clear I don't
like the tone that the president uses
III think there are times where he acts
irrationally and and makes decisions
that are not only not and and and does
things in a way that aren't great for
the Republican Party or for the country
or for him and his agenda for that
matter I mean I think sometimes he can
be his own worst enemy so are you
thinking about running for president
2020
I was just sworn in a month ago for my
second term I've got a lot of work to do
here in Maryland I would say I'm being
approached from a lot of different
people and I guess the best way to put
it is I haven't thrown them out of my
office in 2016 Hogan was one of the most
high-profile Republican officeholders to
withhold support for then candidate
Trump's nomination and little has
changed
would you support him for re-election I
don't see how my position would change
much from before I haven't become more
supportive than I was four years ago I
would say the election is nearly two
years away I don't know who the nominees
in either party are going to be you say
you're not certain who the nominees are
gonna be do you know something we don't
about the president not yet do you know
who they were both gonna be now if the
special counsel report though came back
and found pretty troubling evidence
against the president would that be a
moment at which maybe you have to think
somebody I think well I don't want to
speculate I think you would see a number
of potential challengers in the
Republican Party consider jumping in so
if anything you're issuing him a warning
numbers keep going like that I was
giving him some friendly advice Hogan is
set to take on a far more prominent role
in the coming months as head of the
National Governors Association as part
of that job he's scheduled to visit Iowa
early next month and Nora as we like to
say in this business nobody in politics
visits Iowa by accident nor does he
allow any words to be put in his mouth
and really interesting intervals thank
you so much